et pour en parler nous sommes avec
xavier boy président fédéral de la
fédération autonome des sapeurs pompiers
professionnels et andré goretti
président de la fédération autonome des
sapeurs pompiers professionnels bonjour
à vous merci d'être avec nous ce matin
on a vu cette image forte
c'était en octobre avec ces tensions
entre les sapeurs pompiers et les forces
de l'ordre
et cette question comment est ce qu'on
peut en arriver là aujourd'hui
le ces femmes pour cette manifestation
est une fiction certes après midi on a
fait en sorte que ce genre d'image ne se
reproduise pas parce qu'en fait on s'est
retrouvé menacé à nation sur la place de
la nation les bus étaient derrière le
cortège des forces de l'ordre on arrive
en fin de manifestation où il ya des
tensions
le le parcours on a on est en attente la
délégation reçue au ministère n'est
toujours pas sorti à la révélation du
cortège donc bien les gens commencent à
s'énerver attendent s'impatiente
on veut des réponses notre profession
est en crise il ya un malaise qui
persiste depuis de longues aux
nombreuses années on essaye de le
dénoncer de se faire entendre
on est arrivé une limite on n'a pas de
réponse à nos questionnements à nos
revendications
c'est quand même fort cette image quand
on voit des sapeurs pompiers face aux
forces de l'ordre justement et puis ces
tensions andré goretti
ça veut dire qu'on est assez a quand
même un point à une limite aujourd'hui
dans le cadre des manifestations mais
beaucoup de violences notamment
policières qui sont dénoncées dans le
cadre des manifestations du gilet jaune
mais quand on voit cette image c'est
vrai que ça peut aussi interpellé
il s'agit pour nous de remettre en
question notamment ceux qui passaient
commande d'organiser les manifestions de
la sorte quand je parle d'organiser en
termes de maintien de l'ordre
donc nous ne sommes pas condamnés nous
nos collègues avec qui nous nous
pratiquons le même service il s'agit
aujourd'hui remettre en cause la
commande qui émane du ministère de
l'intérieur donc il est bien derrière
derrière ses prises de position une
commande qui conduit à mettre en défaut
la bonne volonté l'expression
aujourd'hui sapeurs-pompiers au travers
de manifestations
il s'agit pour nous d'alerter la
population sur tous ces
dysfonctionnements
aujourd'hui la plupart de nos
revendications c'est de faire en sorte
que le français comprennent que le
service public de secours n'est plus en
capacité d'absorber toutes les missions
toutes les missions aujourd'hui qui
relève de demain c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous allez battre à nouveau le
pavé aujourd'hui une nouvelle
manifestation
concrètement l'objectif aujourd'hui
c'est quoi c'est bon évidemment vous
avez des revendications c'est la
revalorisation entre autres de la prime
de feu c'est cela c'est une des
revendications en fait on a quatre
revendications principales
c'est l'augmentation des effectifs la
baisse de la sur-sollicitation en fait
des missions sapeurs pompiers
aujourd'hui les pompiers interviennent
sur bon nombre de missions liées au
désengagement des services de l'état que
ce soit des services de police parce que
tout ce qu'ils voient soit public on
engage les sapeurs pompiers ou alors des
transporteurs de sanitaires des semaines
pour les samu en fait tu es quelqu'un
transport de personnes malades
ce n'est pas une mission sapeurs
pompiers et pompiers doivent intervenir
que sur l'urgence des gens qui sont en
détresse vitale un arrêt cardiaque par
exemple
donc en fait toute cette charge
opérationnelle on peut pas la réaliser
aujourd'hui avec les effectifs que l'on
n'a donc vraiment on n'a pas de
revendications salariales
à part cette augmentation de la limite
est de feu qui correspond à la prime de
risque on considère que c'est légitime
d'avoir l'équivalent à ce qu'ils ont les
autres professions à risques comme les
policiers ensuite on a une armée de
questions qui portent sur notre retraite
on est sur une catégorie active donc on
a encore plein de points à faire
concrétiser en fait sur ce que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui le régime existant
est ce qu on nous prévoit sur la réforme
et les violences sur les
sapeurs-pompiers les agressions on veut
qu'ils aient réellement une prise de
conscience de la part de nos gouvernants
pour qu'on soit protégée en intervention
et qu'on puisse intervenir avant d'aller
d'être engagé ça se passe en appel en
arrivant on ne doit pas se retrouver
dans une situation à prendre des coups
de couteau ou tout ça alors vous faisiez
allusion au régime à des retraites
andré goretti vous vous sentez comme
solidaires d'eux des manifestations
aujourd'hui contre cette réforme des
retraites puisque concernant justement
les sapeurs-pompiers le gouvernement a
quand même fait un pas en affirmant que
le régime en fait que votre profession
n'est pas n'est pas vraiment concernés
par la réforme avec un maintien
un départ à 57 ans il nous manque trop
trop d'éléments nous sommes toujours
dans la tente d'abord de malheureusement
dans la publication de cette fois mais
aussi de tous les décrets transversaux
exclusif qui conduiront à positionner
les sapeurs pompiers dans un cadre
totalement différent
aujourd'hui il s'appelait sapeurs
pompiers ne sont pas satisfait du des
éléments qui nous sont qui sont avancés
tout simplement parce que nous partons
sur un principe normalement de
d'équilibré de répartition toute la
population sauf que ce principe même
conduire à ce que les les travailleurs
viendront à capitaliser tout simplement
parce que les montants ne seront plus
suffisant non même si on est sur un
principe de répartition et d'achat de
points puisque il s'agit bien d'une
dispositif universel où on doit se
porter acquéreur de points sur toute la
carrière pour autant est-ce que les
points qui seront achetés par le
travailleur mais en même temps par par
l'employeur suffiront à maintenir un
niveau de pension suffisante pour que
l'on puisse continuer à vivre après
avoir travaillé pendant des années donc
revalorisation de la prime réforme des
retraites surcharge de travail ou en
sont les discussions avec le
gouvernement
alors concernant l'indemnité de feu on a
une proposition que nous avons rejeté
que nous convient pas le ministre
avec les employeurs qui sont les
présidents des conseils départementaux
et les responsables de mairie et de
grosses mairie et de pci nous propose
une augmentation à 5% quand nous on
demande 1 6% par an contre nous
demandent une augmentation à 9 % de
notre dignité de feu 5% étalée sur trois
ans avec la libre appréciation
appréciation de nos employeurs donc en
fait on va avoir des pompiers dans un
département qui pourrait avoir une
augmentation de 6 % d'autres pompiers
par aucune augmentation parce que les
finances ne le permettrait pas donc ça
ne s'est pas entendable on peut pas
accepter
justement avec ce système de retraite
qui arrive derrière qui sera liée à la
rémunération peut pas accepter les
différences de traitement déjà
qu'aujourd'hui on dénonce des
différences de distribution de secours
en fonction des territoires en france
pour conclure andré goretti vous
attendez beaucoup de monde aujourd'hui
nous espérons nous espérons les nos
collègues sont très motivés vont
exprimer leur mécontentement face à des
situations qui aujourd'hui est
exceptionnel puisque c'est la première
fois que nous connaissons une durée
aussi importante en termes d'engagements
sur un mouvement social
merci beaucoup à vous pour avoir été
avec nous ce matin je rappelle que andré
goretti vous êtes président national de
la fédération autonome des sapeurs
pompiers professionnels merci à vous fin